en los últimos vídeos tratamos de
encontrar si hay una diferencia
significativa entre la proporción de los
hombres que probablemente voten por
cierto candidato y la proporción de
mujeres que voten por el mismo candidato
en el vídeo anterior estimamos esto
usando un intervalo de confianza del 95%
para la diferencia entre la proporción
de hombres y la diferencia entre la
proporción de mujeres lo que haremos en
este vídeo es hacer la pregunta de forma
más directa al hacer una prueba de
hipótesis para ver si existe una
diferencia establecemos la hipótesis
nula la hipótesis nula es que no hay
diferencia entre la forma en que votarán
los hombres y las mujeres otra forma de
pensar en esto es que la proporción de
hombres que votarán por el candidato
será igual a la proporción de mujeres
que votarán por el candidato y otra
forma de pensar en esto es que la
diferencia entre p1 y p2 es decir la
diferencia entre la proporción verdadera
de la población de hombres que votarán
por el candidato menos la proporción
verdadera de la población de mujeres que
votarán por el candidato será igual a
cero
es la hipótesis nula la hipótesis
alternativa dice que si existe una
diferencia o que uno no es igual a p2p
uno que es la proporción verdadera de la
población de hombres que votan menos
pedos
la proporción verdadera de las mujeres
que votan no es igual a cero vamos a
hacer esta prueba de hipótesis con un
nivel de significancia de 5%
esto significa que como lo hemos visto
anteriormente vamos a suponer que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera y si
suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera vamos a calcular la
probabilidad de obtener la diferencia
entre las proporciones muestrales de los
hombres y las proporciones muestrales de
las mujeres dado que suponemos que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera si esta
probabilidad es menor al 5% que es el
nivel de significancia que elegimos
entonces vamos a rechazar la hipótesis
nula como vamos a hacer esto si
suponemos la hipótesis nula cómo se
empieza a ver la distribución muestral
de este estadístico pues la media
suponiendo que las proporciones
verdaderas de las poblaciones de hombres
y mujeres son iguales
es decir que uno y dos son iguales
entonces esto va a ser igual a cero lo
que podemos hacer es encontrar el
resultado de restar la proporción de
hombres y la proporción de mujeres esta
es la proporción muestral de los hombres
que en la encuesta respondieron que van
a votar por el candidato esta es la
proporción muestral de las mujeres que
van a votar por el candidato la
diferencia entre estas dos es de 0.0 51
lo que podemos hacer es calcular cuál es
la probabilidad de que suponiendo que
las proporciones verdaderas sean iguales
y que la media de la distribución
muestral de este estadístico sea
realmente cero obtengamos una diferencia
de 0.0 51 cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener algo así de extremo vamos a
calcular un puntaje z para ver a cuántas
desviaciones estándar de la media se
encuentra esto este será el puntaje z y
luego veremos si la probabilidad de
obtener esta desviación estándar un
resultado tan extremo o que esté a
tantas desviaciones estándar de la media
es mayor o menor a 5% si es menor a 5%
entonces vamos a rechazarla
tesis nula calculemos primero el puntaje
z suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera la cual dice que p 1 es igual
a p 2 el puntaje z a cuantas
desviaciones estándar de la media está
el resultado verdadero o la diferencia
real entre hombres y mujeres que muestre
amos en los últimos vídeos es de 0.0 51
y a este valor le vamos a restar la
media supuesta recuerden que suponemos
que estas dos cosas son iguales por lo
que la media de esta distribución
muestral es cero así que restamos cero y
luego tenemos que dividir esto entre la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral de este estadístico de 1 - p 2
cuál será la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral en el vídeo
anterior encontramos que podemos
representarla con esta fórmula pero con
la hipótesis nula suponemos que p1 y p2
tienen el mismo valor vamos a reescribir
lo aunque en el vídeo anterior hicimos
esta aproximación y no quiero que nos
confunda así que vamos a escribir aquí
la versión en limpio sabemos que la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral que es esto de aquí
estadístico de la media muestral de p 1
menos la media muestral de p 2 es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de p uno por uno
menos uno entre mil más p dos por uno p
dos entre mil ya hemos visto esto en
varios vídeos pero en la hipótesis nula
suponemos que p 1 es igual a pedos eso
es lo que hacemos suponemos que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera y calculamos
la probabilidad de que esto ocurra type
1 es igual a pedos entonces podemos
representarlos como una proporción
verdadera de la población p podemos
decir que esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de factor izamos 1 entre 1000 y
lo multiplicamos por p por 1 - p más p
por 1 - p porque 1 y p2 tienen el mismo
valor es lo que suponemos en la
hipótesis nula así que aquí tenemos dos
de lo mismo esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 p por 1 - p entre 1000 una
vez más esta es la desviación estándar
de la distribución del estadístico de la
media muestral de los hombres menos la
media muestral de las mujeres
aún no conocemos la proporción verdadera
pero la podemos estimar al usar las
muestras y como suponemos que no hay
diferencia entre los hombres y las
mujeres podemos considerar que la
muestra tiene un tamaño de 2000 para
calcular la proporción verdadera así que
podemos sustituir esto con la proporción
muestral podemos pretender que la
encuesta de hombres y mujeres fue solo
una encuesta muy grande la proporción
muestra al base de igual a la encuesta
de una población de 2.000 personas
fueron 1000 hombres y 1000 mujeres y
vamos a suponer que no hay diferencia
entre ellos ya que de eso trata la
hipótesis nula de que no hay diferencia
entre hombres y mujeres veamos el dato
anterior tenemos 600 42 votos a favor
entre los hombres y tenemos 591 votos a
favor entre las mujeres por lo que
tenemos un total de 642 más 591 si vemos
esto como una encuesta grande de dos mil
personas entonces tenemos sacamos la
calculadora tenemos que 642 más 591 es
igual a 1.233 dividido entre 2000 es
0.6 mil 165 esta es la mejor estimación
de esta proporción poblacional
consistente que es verdadera tanto para
hombres como para mujeres porque estamos
suponiendo que no son diferentes ahora
podemos sustituir pp por este valor para
estimar la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral de este
estadístico de acá nuevamente suponiendo
que no hay diferencia entre la
proporción de hombres y mujeres que
votan por el candidato la raíz cuadrada
de 2 por p qué es 0.6 mil 165 por 1 - p
o 1 menos 0.6 mil 165 dividido entre
vamos a revisar 2 por p este 0.6 1.165
es p x 1 menos 0.6 1.165 dividido entre
1000 y calculamos la raíz cuadrada de
todo esto obtenemos que la desviación
estándar es de 0.0 217 vamos a
escribirlo aquí arriba esto es 0.0 217
así que si queremos encontrar el puntaje
en cuanto a sus visiones estándar de la
media supuesta está la muestra verdadera
del estadístico que obtuvimos recordemos
que es cuando suponemos que no hay
diferencia entonces dividimos 0.0 51
entre esta desviación estándar vamos a
hacerlo
0.0 51 entre esta desviación estándar
que es la respuesta anterior nos da como
resultado que está a 2.35 desviación es
el puntaje z es igual a 2.35 repasemos
lo que hicimos al suponer que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera la cual dice
que no hay diferencia la distribución
muestral de este estadístico tendrá una
media de 0 y el resultado que obtuvimos
para el estadístico es un puntaje z de
2.35 también podemos decir que esto es
equivalente a estar a 2.35 desviaciones
estándar de esta media de 0 para
rechazar la hipótesis nula ésta tiene
que tener una probabilidad menor al
nivel de significancia veamos cuál es el
puntaje z mínimo necesario para rechazar
la hipótesis nula pensemos un momento al
respecto veamos de nuevo la tabla zeta
queremos un nivel de significancia de 5%
lo que significa que toda el área para
la cual podemos rechazar la hipótesis
nula es de 5% esta es una prueba
bilateral de dos colas un evento extremo
que puede estar muy por arriba o muy por
debajo de la media nos permitirá
rechazar la hipótesis nula el área que
nos interesa es esta de 2.5 por ciento y
esta otra también de 2.5 por ciento de
manera que nos queda 95% en medio así
que tenemos que encontrar este valor z
crítico si nuestro valor z es mayor que
la versión positiva de este valor se
está crítico entonces podemos decir que
la probabilidad de obtener un valor tan
extremo es menor del 5% suponiendo que
la hipótesis nula es correcta y entonces
podemos rechazar la hipótesis nula
veamos cuál es este valor crítico
queremos un valor z que tenga un
porcentaje por debajo de 97.5 por ciento
porque de esta forma aquí tendremos 2.5
por ciento de hecho ya habíamos
encontrado este valor en el vídeo
anterior esta área acumulada tiene que
ser de 97.5 por ciento
en la tabla tenemos el 0.900 75 el cual
tiene un puntaje z de 1.96 así que el
valor z crítico es de 1.96 esto nos dice
que hay una probabilidad de 5% de
muestrear un estadístico z mayor a 1.96
suponiendo que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera
ahora ya encontramos que muestre a mos
un estadístico z de 2.35 suponiendo que
se cumple la hipótesis nula por lo que
la probabilidad de muestrear esto la
probabilidad de que z sea igual a 2.35
dada la hipótesis nula va a ser menor de
5% es más extremo que este valor se está
crítico y debido a esto podemos rechazar
la hipótesis nula disculpen por tanto
movimiento de la pantalla pero es que ya
escribimos muchas cosas aquí y hay que
aprovecharlas de nuevo como la
probabilidad de obtener esto al suponer
la hipótesis nula es menor a 5% que es
el nivel de significancia podemos
rechazar la hipótesis nula y podemos
decir que existe una diferencia no
estamos 100%
de que haya una diferencia pero
estadísticamente se está a favor de la
hipótesis alternativa que sugiere que
hay una diferencia entre la proporción
de hombres y la proporción de mujeres
que votarán por el candidato nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo